all right Nancy uh from one scary
situation to another and that's the
story that you were originally at the
White House to cover for us this morning
and that is the debt ceiling
negotiations uh could be a hold up on
cash for seniors for the military if
things don't have a breakthrough where
do they stand
yes this is more of a slow motion
Collision we're now one day closer to
the deadline with no agreement to Stave
off a default the speaker and the
president met here at the White House
again yesterday they vowed to talk every
day until they get a deal but there
aren't that many days left
we still have some disagreements the
president and the speaker called their
Monday meeting productive but they did
not produce a deal I think the tone
tonight was better than any other time
we've had discussions and so negotiators
got back to work last night haggling
over spending cuts Republicans are
seeking in exchange for their votes to
raise the nation's borrowing limit
failure to raise it in the next nine
days could result in the first ever U.S
government default it's time for the
extreme Mega Republicans in the House of
Representatives
to get real
about the crisis that they have created
without the ability to borrow the
federal government might have to put on
hold paychecks for 4 million government
workers and benefits for nearly 70
million Social Security recipients this
is what we live on Virginia retiree
Sharon Jenkins says without that monthly
check she can afford to pay her rent but
that's about it and I worked very hard
for that Social Security and I think I'm
owed that Social Security and I don't
think the government has the right to
take it away from me the latest White
House offer would keep government
spending flat for the next two years
Republicans want to cut spending further
and then cap it for six years with one
major exception defense should not be on
the table it's a responsibility the
treasury secretary sent yet another
letter to lawmakers Monday reminding
them that it is highly likely treasury
will no longer be able to pay all the
government's bills come early June
and if Wall Street starts to get worried
the economy could take a hit even sooner
markets will start to unravel stock
prices will decline interest rates will
rise it'll be tougher to get a loan and
ultimately if it continues on for very
long and we breach then we'll have a
recession
President Biden has been pushing for tax
revenue to be a part of this deal
closing loopholes for the wealthy and
corporations but speaker McCarthy has
rejected that he and the president still
insist they can make an agreement in
time and for now the markets appear to
be content with that
the country is watching let's hope they
work this out sooner rather than later
thank you Nancy